I did and like I told you, I'm not going
anywhere else no more in Los Angeles.
I'm going back to the store,
no improv science spots,
especially after I shot the
Netflix special and everything.
It all came to me after that, that 10
years and especially after she died.
You know how people,
you ever go to like an acting class
and people refer to Stanislavski.
I don't know all this shit.
10 years from now people are going to be
referring to the Mitzi short technique.
There was something that every car I
was talking with a dunk and it by it.
I talked to Ari about it.
I know she said something to us at
one point that we were like, wow,
something I remember
who is Thomas on my podcast that there
was a times she didn't like you doing
that in the cobit and the mass
swing.
Let me do it in the main room in the
original. How fucking crazy as that.
That's to show you how genius in
a way, like she was like, Joe,
you could light yourself on fire. And
they originally, I don't give a fuck,
but in the main room you can't do
that because you're killing my room.
Like the comics afterwards
just could not follow it.
Like they could just not
follow that lesson right there.
That was about it was brilliant,
but it think about it.
There's no good versions of that bit
anywhere. This one version than I did.
That's up on you.
It's terrible.
It's a terrible version that there's
no solid versions of that pit.
But that bit was right when that guy died.
J Howard Marshall and myself that him
getting Anna Nicole Smith to do shit to
him before he died. Father,
she's trying to take your money.
I don't give a fuck. I want to get
my boss' leg or something like that.
The crazy bit.
But Mitzi didn't like it too because she
didn't like bits that were making fun
of old people cause you know,
her health was deteriorating till she,
there was a couple of bits of it.
She didn't like
fucking picture him.
He's a million years old and she's hot
as the sun and she's sitting on his lap.
Look at him. Look at the smile on his
face. Dog. Yeah. Oh Man. I loved him.
I loved that whole scene.
I loved what it was.
I loved it because it was so blatant.
You know? It was just so blatant.
But she didn't like that bit. She
didn't like the Hugh Hefner bid either.
She didn't like that bit.
When you have to told those really
good and she's kissing them. Oh,
I Jesus Christ.
Oh,
he's in a wheelchair where
she's married him. I mean,
it was a damn classic that, that, that,
that scene of him and her getting married.
She's so young and so hot and he's so old,
wrecked and rich as fuck in a wheelchair.
It's such a classic scenario.
It was so good call though.
Kentucky Fried Hookah.
I had him card, Kentucky Fried. If
she wanted that money, she had it.
She had to keep doing shit.
That shit.
He's calling father.
That's awesome. This like,
it's time to lick my
it's time. Yeah, man.
I just love the fact that that guy
was that wealthy and yet still,
I mean,
I guess when you're that well,
was he born at that time
more than a billion dollars?
Yeah. He was a billionaire.
He was an oil magnate, right? Wasn't he?
I don't think she got the money though.
I think the kids fought her
hundred Maillian what?
That's peanuts. Yeah,
it got hot dog and Nicole Smith's daughter
is now the fourth richest woman in
the u s it's what? Oh, I know.
It says 37 billion now let's Koch,
Koch brothers.
Oh, I see. I see. He was
69th on the list. Ah,
but fourth richest woman. Do you know,
out of the richest women in the world,
Google the richest women in the world,
like where they got their money from?
It's rough.
It's rough out there guys.
They ain't fucking starting
businesses that Mary had. Dummies.
Really? Is that how it goes? Divorced?
Almost all of its divorce money.